- Hey, guys, it's Justine,
and this is my sister Jenna.
- Hello.
- Actual real legit sister.
Sometimes they think that
we're sorority sisters.
- No!
We're too old for that.
- No, no, no, no.
(thuds)
- She is.
(Justine gasps)
- Speaking of being too old for things,
I recently did a video
where I was cutting soap,
and some of you guys loved it,
some of you hated it,
some of you were confused.
I also was confused in the
entire making of the video,
but I thought I would bring
my sister along for the fun,
because--
- So I could be confused
as well?
- Yes, well we're gonna
be cutting soap today.
You saw my last video didn't you?
You don't watch my videos, that's
totally fine, I'm not even upset about it.
- I was in the same room
when she was filming it.
I feel like I don't have to watch it.
- So previously, I used
some fairly large knives,
but I thought let's up it a little bit.
Let's get a bigger knife
and add another person.
(crackling)
This here is my machete.
- What! (laughs)
No, no, I gotta go.
I've got an appointment.
- (laughs) Where's your appointment?
Tell me, show me, it's not on your iCal.
Let's cut soap.
(whacks)
Okay.
(Jenna gasps)
So, to be honest with you guys,
what I learned in my first
video, is cutting soap
with a smaller knife, is
actually a lot easier,
but I thought we should
probably test this out.
The thing about this is it's really good,
for hacking down weeds and
things like that outside.
You have to be really swinging.
This is not something that is good,
for what I'm gonna be doing. (laughs)
- So, why am I here,
because there's no space,
for me up there?
(both laugh)
- Oh, hello.
- I don't like it.
- Okay, well, then let's start small.
Let's cut just maybe something
tiny just to give you,
a taste of what we're gonna do.
- Okay, but you're pointing
the blade where my body goes.
Yeah, set it down.
I have a question why
does this soap have...
- That's an Easter bunny.
- What do you do with this soap?
Is it like a bath bomb or do
you like rub your body on it?
This one matches me.
- It's giving me a headache.
- But no, seriously, what do
I do with this fancy soap?
- I think, I don't know.
- Is this a bomb?
- The girl was very confused,
as to why I was buying
so much soap. (laughs)
- [Jenna] This looks like a cookie,
I feel like I should be eating it.
- You shouldn't. 'Cause, here,
I'm gonna give you the little
knife, because it's actually a lot more
fun, to cut with a smaller one.
- [Jenna] And what
should I do, should I...
- Do whatever you want.
This is your soap cut.
Oh gosh.
This looks like an Oreo cookie.
- So does this.
- [Justine] So you should probably,
no, so maybe start on this side.
So, see this, 'cause you just kinda...
See, look, you wanna do like
nice little slices like this.
- [Jenna] Sure,
(upbeat music)
sure.
- [Justine] Aw, they're gonna hate mine.
That's a nice cut, and then just scoot
it out of the way so they can really see,
and you wanna cut real thin slices,
like ooh.
- Sure.
- [Justine] Did you see that cut?
- [Jenna] Sure.
So it's the wrong hand. (laughs)
- I'm ambidextrous, so I can switch.
Here let's switch.
- I'm making a mess.
- Here.
See, look, yeah.
(thuds)
- [Jenna] Wow, see they're
just much nicer to cut.
(thuds)
- [Justine] This is beautiful.
So what do you guys think
of dual soap cutting?
(thuds)
- I wonder what slow-mo finger
slice is gonna look like.
- [Justine] I hope we don't find out.
- [Jenna] Are these gonna be in slow-mo?
- Oh yeah.
- [Jenna] So, Jenna, what
do you do for a living?
Well, I was thinking the same
thing, when I did the first video.
I thought about what led me to the point,
in my life where I'm
cutting soap on YouTube?
- I've got two
science degrees.
- I do the same.
(mumbles) filming you cutting soap.
- Jenna and her science degree,
Nick shooting feature
films and documentaries,
but today, my friends, we are taking
all of that knowledge, and we are throwing
it out the window.
(Jenna laughs)
- Throw it out the window!
Do what you want, cut soap!
So now I think we need
to test out the machete.
We're gonna give it a
big cut with this one.
(thuds)
I'll do it.
- Well I, I've gotta...
- You should probably back up.
- I've gotta go.
- To be honest with you.
- Where should I go?
Think I'm safe back here?
- Probably.
Depends how... (laughs)
- Well, oh, wait.
I'm in the worst spot.
- I didn't hit it in the middle.
(whacks)
(scrapes)
Now is the point where you think,
"Oh, what led me to
this point in my life?"
(clangs)
Does it look good, do you think?
What the heck is in here?
- I don't know, but you
just dropped something.
I'm gonna get down, so
please don't swing your chet.
- Oh, God, this stinks.
This is disgusting.
I hate everything about this smell.
- [Jenna] What's this?
- Oh, here, you cut that half.
Just a little chalky.
(thuds)
It's very, very vibrant.
Nothing this color should be touching
your skin, unless it's a freaking carrot.
(thuds)
So next up, what do we have?
- [Jenna] Let's just jab it.
Just straight up
- Wait!
- give it a jab.
(thuds)
- Oh, I thought you were gonna winding up.
Yeah, that's nice.
(thuds)
Oh...
Okay, this looks good.
- Oh, this is a nice
cranberry smell.
- This is like a muffin!
Oh, look at the cut.
- This smells good.
I'll give you $10 to eat it.
- [Justine] $10?
- [Jenna] Just take a bite.
- That would--
- But then I'll have
to take you to the emergency room.
- [Justine] That wouldn't even pay
for how much the soap cost me. (thuds)
- [Jenna] That's your own fault.
(thuds)
(scrapes)
- Oh, I'll do it that way, too.
(thuds)
- [Jenna] Oh, I don't know,
I'm just goin' to town.
- [Justine] You never go to town!
(thuds)
- (mumbles) go to town on the soap!
(scrapes)
Just still don't understand.
(thuds)
- [Justine] There's nothing, sometimes,
Jenna, you just need to accept the fact
that we're cutting soap
and this is the life that
we're living right now.
- This looks like an onion.
I've never cut an onion,
but onions are gross.
- I'd say that looks like a beet.
Okay, I think that's enough.
Oh, look at this one.
This looks like...
Like a gallbladder?
- [Jenna] Let's cut it. (mumbles)
- [Justine] You're not even on the screen.
- Well, you're shoving me off!
(scrapes)
All that hard work to not be noticed.
(thuds)
(Justine laughs)
This one feels like makeup.
Is this makeup?
- [Justine] Oh, it might be, I don't know.
Hmm.
- [Jenna] Is this a bronzer?
- Ooh, look how nice.
This is my palette.
This is the...
Oh, wow. How do we get
that off of our bodies?
So, guys, that was Cutting Soap Part
Two, Machete and Jenna Style.
The machete does not work very well.
I don't recommend it if
you plan on doing this.
It's also potentially dangerous,
but I think--
- Well, what about this bunny?
(Justine gasps)
- [Justine] Let's give
it, I'll dig in there.
Let's dig in there.
Oh, it's a little pompom.
Oh, my, look at that.
(thuds)
(slams)
This is the last soap we have.
(thuds)
Jenna, what did you think
about the soap experience?
- It was fun.
(thuds)
- Oh, this smells good!
Ooh, it's like a lemon.
- Yeah, this one smells
like, oh it smells like PEZ.
- Mmm, oh my gosh.
- Oh, my God, lemon PEZ!
Should we start a new thing
(Justine gasps)
where we cut PEZ?
- Yeah!
(thuds)
- Why not?
- [Justine] This looks beautiful.
- [Jenna] Yeah, it was fun.
(thuds)
- [Justine] Would you do it again?
- Well, why wouldn't I
as long as you're buyin'?
- Alright.
- Boop.
- Ugh.
Well, guys, that was Cutting Soap
Part Two here on my channel.
Thank you, Jenna, for
cutting soap with me.
- Thank you for having me.
(both laugh)
- I'm sure you're so ecstatic.
What did you think of this experience?
- It was fun.
- Did you
enjoy it, or...
- I definitely enjoyed
the little slices, was
very nice and smooth.
Some of the smells
weren't that great, but...
- Yeah, I feel a little
nauseous, to be honest with you.
- I definitely have a headache.
- Yeah.
If you guys liked this video, hit like,
if you wanna subscribe,
you can click subscribe,
and you can go check out Jenna's channel.
It's me jennae.
I'll put all the links in the description,
and I will see you guys in the next video.
Don't know what that video's gonna be.
- Yeah, what's it gonna be?
- Who knows?
- Ooh.
- My channel is a mix of a lot of things.
I'll see you guys later.
Bye!
(smooth music)